[Music]
incredible shape you're in for someone
who's let himself go absolutely yeah
what to do well it's you know what's
your secret red bull and whippets i mean
that's what
that's where the energy comes from no no
i listen you have to stay slim trim yes
and uh even you know when i was my kids
were little i you know at easter i would
have them hunt for easter egg whites you
know it was always
too much yeah it's too much that's and i
don't believe it i think that's some
kind of
rascally joke no i'm doing atkins are
you really not the diet his widow i'm
you know
[Applause]
because i feel you have to
[Applause]
you're a bad man oh i think i'm sweet
uh now i i have to ask you about this uh
ask me anything it was actually in the
tabloids it's conan right oh yes
you son of a [ __ ]
you and i shouldn't put that here well
you can do whatever you like that's the
way it works
here in old russia
[Music]
what are we doing i don't know what was
that
it's stuff like that and it's that kind
of instinct that kept me
out of the big money
on my gravestone there'll be one word
yes almost oh no
no you're wrong really yes oh you're so
sweet yes yes now you've got to tell me
about you and steve martin you vacation
together you and steve martin are good
pals and and uh i understand you went to
the caribbean the island of saint barts
that's true and and he um sometimes uh
stays there and will invite me down and
this is a true story so there's no
pressure for it to be funny because it's
actually a completely true story so so
down there you know in st bart's you see
a lot of pictures of you know people on
the beach
celebrities all the celebrities go and
because the paparazzi literally
hide in the bushes and if you're on the
beach and you're strolling along you're
saying oh isn't that a lovely uh sand
castle there and then they get that
picture you know yeah
and uh i didn't know he was with child
you know
especially when you're picking you know
they look for the worst one yeah so um
anyway so he had this idea he was like
he'd been there for a week and he'd been
following around and he'd go shopping
with his wife and they'd take pictures
and go to the beach he was driving
crying crazy so he knew i was coming so
he thought oh it's going to be worse
because whenever you get more than one
celebrity or a celebrity and a
personality whatever that combination is
you get them together i won't hear it
all right and then so he thought i know
what i'll do because he's a big tweeter
he has 2.2 million followers so what he
thought he'd do he said okay i've got
the idea so what we'll do is we'll go to
a private beach and then we'll take a
picture of the two of us in a goofy
picture and then i'll tweet it and then
it will usurp the market right now the
paparazzi won't have any market and then
they'll leave us alone all the photos of
you guys won't be worth anything because
it's already out there so he had this
idea uh so we went to a a store we've
got props we've got a bucket we've got a
little um uh uh you know
shovels shovel trouble
i didn't know what i was going through
no i didn't know either but your space
work was so good yeah yeah it is like
having marcel marcel yeah yeah and um so
so anyway and and we got an inflatable
alligator and the picture was well i put
my hair up as a grimling and i got the
pants high and the idea that he'd have
his arm around me and say even though
i'm in st parts i still have time to
take care of the village idiot
and he tweeted that picture and let's
just show that picture we have it right
we actually have oh no no no
look at that
that's yes
that is the picture
let's just tweet it out yeah now so so
everything's good so everything's fine
everything so that he said you see now
we'll be left alone and you won't see
any stupid pictures of yourself in
magazines so then about a week ago i'm
i'm going to chicago i was doing a
benefit at notre dame university and my
son goes and i'm in the back of a limo
and i pick out star
magazine and
oh i'm sorry when we took this picture
on this beach there was this homeless
guy at the end and i thought he couldn't
be a paparazzi could he and i thought
nah there's no way and so anyway i'm on
my way to notre dame and i see this
picture yeah uh this is what i saw in
the magazine
and this is what they seem to have
cropped out that you're with anybody
[Applause]
so it didn't quite work now
[Applause]
you look at 61 years of age can you
imagine how my kids feel